j'ai quelques amis donc Guillaume
battent qui est un mes meilleurs amis
après enfin avec Guillaume en fait on
passe notre temps à s'insulter enfin on
s'écrit tous les jours mais en vrai on
se fait que se dire des saloperies à
longueur de journée il y a vraiment
aucun filtre Guillaume et moi quand on
parle je pense que beaucoup de gens
seraient vraiment choqués de voir le
contenu de conversation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
in the big house oui
j'ai peur en fait je suis en train de me
dire ça et j'ai peur je suis en train de
réaliser je trouvais que c'est une bonne
idée pour le travail pas forcément pour
l'accompagnement
on va vite le mettre au travail
[Rires]